there's more of like i remember a
conversation in college i had with a
friend that i'm
still friend with friends with and has
had a lot of success on broadway on his
own now but i remember at the time like
it almost like he was frustrated with me
and like i was almost
getting under his skin that like because
i'm not a cocky like overconfident
person by any means i actually am like
very insecure a lot of the time and beat
myself
very self-loathing but like you said
like i mean i
was like why would i be doing this if i
didn't think like oh yeah i'm gonna be
on broadway oh yeah i'm gonna be able to
do this like why would i be
why would i be doing this if i didn't
believe that i'll have success
yeah that's what i understand i think
there's some people that you know i have
friends that just like i know i just
want to do this should i do this i don't
if you're saying should i or i don't
then there's then there's no there's
only
there's those people i want to be a
doctor i want to save people
this is what i want to do there's not
like i don't know should i be a doctor
or should i be
i think you get to a point where like i
know what i'm destined to be whether
it's doing theater in a small town and
not making any money or becoming a movie
star or whatever
this is what i want to do yeah and i was
fine with that i mean i also knew that
that was a possibility and i knew i
would have been happy like
doing regional theater in different like
states and cities all the time and like
knowing that i was following my passion
i definitely pictured that life
sometimes too you know
it was the the least successful version
of what i wanted to do and i was fine
with that